[Applaudissements]
la première fois
j'ai posé la main sur une percussion
c'était sur une percussion africaine
la première fois que j'ai posé la main
sur une percussion
j'ai su que ma vie allait changer
j'ai su que ma vie allait changer car il
s'est passé quelque chose de magique un
plaisir instantané
un ressenti jamais vécu la première fois
que j'ai posé la main sur une percussion
j'ai su que ma vie allait changer car
avant ce moment bien précis je n'aurais
jamais pensé pouvoir devenir musicien
c'est cet instrument le djembé qui m'a
donné envie d'aller plus loin
c'est cet instrument qui m'a donné envie
de réaliser quelque chose qui aurait pu
être juste un rêve mais qui au final est
devenu réalité
c'est cet instrument qui m'a donné envie
de devenir musicien
la première fois que j'ai posé la main
sur une percussion
c'était aux états unis et j'ai joué avec
quatre personnes nous avons joué
ensemble en rythme avec une cadence un
tempo commun nous avons joué ensemble de
manière coordonnée et moi je jouais pour
la première fois d'un instrument de
musique avec d'autres personnes
ce moment bien précis était un point de
départ car le lendemain je suis allé
acheter ma première percussion
puis peu de temps après je suis rentré
en france où le début d'une quête était
lancée une quête d'apprentissage une
recherche de savoir une recherche de
plaisir
une quête plein d'objectifs la quête
d'une nouvelle passion jouer des
percussions puis s'il a fallu rencontrer
des gens et j'ai rencontré rémy moi j'ai
vécu à peu près la même rencontre avec
l'instrument que michael une sorte
de coup de foudre un mélange entre le
toucher du cuir
la beauté des veines du bois sculpté et
surtout l'énergie l'énergie qui entraîne
qui fait qu'un coup porté une frappe en
appelle une autre puis une autre puis
une autre et peu de temps après jetée
dans un train je revenais de paris où
j'avais fait l'aller retour pour aller
chercher mon premier tambours j'ai
commencé à apprendre tout seul en
autodidacte en testant en essayant en
développant peu à peu mes techniques
j'ai progressé en me criant mes propres
façons de faire et je crois que c'est ça
qui me stimulait le plus au début puis
j'ai incité mes amis proches a joué avec
moi et je suis parti en afrique un peu
au hasard mais pour voir comment comment
devait réellement se jouer cet
instrument et en rentrant j'ai rencontré
michael dans une toute petite salle de
répétition mais qui allait devenir très
très importante pour nous comment
devenir musicien c'est la question que
nous nous sommes posée est tout d'abord
nous pensions qu'il fallait privilégier
le savoir avant tout mais le temps nous
a appris qu'il nous manquait quelque
chose d'énorme quelque chose qui
rendrait tout le reste beaucoup plus
simple il nous manquait une équipe
c'est d'ailleurs en se regroupant avec
d'autres percussionniste que nous avons
réussi à apprendre à jouer d'un
instrument qui appartient à une culture
différente de la nôtre
j'aimerais partager avec vous ce que
nous avons vécu si je devais expliquer à
un enfant de cinq ans ce qui est un
rythme je lui dirai qu'un rythme c'est
une phrase qui se répète se répètent
jusqu'à ce que quelqu'un décide qu'elle
s'arrête une phrase ça pourrait être ça
lui tu vas bien et si je voulais mettre
salut tu vas bien en rythme je pourrais
faire ça lui tu vas bien salut tu vas
bien salut tu vas bien mais ça ce ne
sont que des mots et en rythme avec mes
mains je pourrai décider de faire un
deux trois et bien prenons un de 3com
phrases et si je voulais que nous
fassions tous ensemble cette phrase
devrait compter 1 2 3 4 et 1 2 3 1 2 3 4
nous permettrait à tous deux commencé en
même temps et à la même vitesse
eh bien j'aimerais que nous essayons
ensemble avec vos mains êtes vous prêts
c'est parti 2 3 4 t une fois on leur
fait une fois 1 2 3 4 t
très bien et bien maintenant je voudrais
qu'on fasse cette phrase deux fois de
suite comme ça êtes vous prêt de 1 2 3 4
t maintenant que nous en sommes là nous
allons pouvoir faire cette phrase et la
jouer sans cesse sans cesse jusqu'à ce
que je recompte 1 2 3 4 pour que nous
arrêtions ensemble ça fera comme ça un
peu 3 4 t stop et là nous terminons par
un temps êtes vous prêts c'est parti 1 2
3 4 tu es un peu trois quatre testeurs
très bien et de maintenant moi je vais
demander à cette partie là de la salle à
partir d'ici voilà de jouer exactement
la même chose sauf qu'on va rajouter un
coup au début un coup tout seul on va
l'appeler cadeau parce qu'après on le
reverra plus d'accord ça va faire 1 1 2
3 1 2 3 vous avez compris on y va juste
vous 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4
super mais maintenant essayons de faire
ça avec lui l'autre moitié de la salle
qui elle n'a pas changé du tout la
phrase donc pour vous avec michael 1 2 3
1 2 3 et vous un teint de 3 1 but 3
attention un deux trois quatre
1 2 3 4
super et bien maintenant changeons la
phrase disons pour les trois premiers
rangs devant les trois premiers rendre
devant ici on va faire 1 et 2 et 1 2 3
et 1 et 2 et 1 2 3 d'accord michael le
fait avec vous avec le pied pour garder
c'est pour ça que c'est les rendre
devant attention juste vous 1 2 3 4
un peu 3 4 super maintenant qu'on en est
là on va essayer les trois mélangez vous
là bas toujours à 22 3 1 2 3 6 6 1 1 2 3
1 2 3 et vous 1 2 1 2 3 ça marche
attention 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4
très bien j'aimerais maintenant que nous
affrontions un unis sont un unisson
c'est une phrase que tout le monde joue
en même temps et nous notre unisson ce
sera 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
j'aimerais qu'on essaye de cette phrase
1 2 3 4 t encore une fois
1 2 3 4 t et bien cette unissons nous
allons le placer tout à la fin de notre
rythme je vais donc compté jusque 4 et
chacun jouera sa phrase sans cesse sans
cesse jusqu'à ce que je recompte jusque
quatre pour que nous fassions cette unis
sont 7 partie 2 3 4 t
1 2 3 4 et oi oi oi oi
ce que nous venons de vivre
c'est une expérience musicale collective
est selon nous ça commence par ça être
musicien
enfin en percussion en tout cas ça
commence par ça et quelles que soient
les endroits où nous intervenons que ce
soit dans des écoles
que ce soit dans des entreprises des
établissements de soins partout où nous
allons
lorsque nous disons nous allons jouer de
la musique ensemble des réactions sont
nombreuses dont des réactions telles que
moi je suis pas musicien ou alors rage
est vraiment pas le sens du rythme et et
pourtant par expérience partout partout
tout le monde a toujours réussi
tout le monde a toujours réussi à
s'emparer du rythme et à le vivre avec
les autres
dès nos premières expériences avec la
percussion nous sommes rendus compte
qu'en mélangeant des phrases simples il
était facile de jouer des choses
complexes
là nous voulons dans mélangez 2 et en
avons fait une polyrythmie la
polyrythmie c'est le mélange de
plusieurs rythmes qui donne naissance à
un nouveau rythme qui transcende les
autres dernièrement je suis allé voir
sur internet et j'ai découvert qu'il
existait des listings disant aux gens
comment faire pour devenir musicien et
sur une liste de 17 points
je me suis rendu compte que je vois en
groupe était placé à la 13e position
il fallait d'abord choisir un instrument
s'y intéresser en apprendre la technique
apprendre à lire le solfège et même
apprendre à composer la musique
tout ça avant jouer en groupe nous
sommes rendu compte par le biais des
percussions il était plus intéressant de
passer l'équipe en premier car c'est
l'équipe qui allait nous permettre
d'apprendre et cette expérience
collective est riche
riche parce que la musique fait appel
directement aux émotions et partager une
expérience musicale collective ensemble
c'est partager des émotions
or il est peu de chose qui soit aussi
puissante que de partager une émotion
avec quelqu'un d'autre et partager des
émotions
ce n'est pas de l'empathie partager des
émotions lorsque l'on joue de la musique
ensemble
c'est de la sympathie c'est vibrer
ensemble si je gratte une corde de
guitare accordéon mis à proximité d'une
autre corde à cordes est pareil
la seconde va se mettre à vibrer sans
que l'on n'y touche par sympathie et
c'est ça l'expérience musicale
collective en percussion c'est vibrer
ensemble vibrer avec l'autre vibrer avec
l'autre ça veut dire trouver sa place et
être avec l'autre être avec l'autre mais
en tant que personne en tant qu individu
à part entière tout en faisant partie du
groupe
prenons comme exemple la musique
brésilienne
vous avez tous entendu parler du
carnaval de rio et bien dans ce carnaval
on y trouve des orchestres groupe rend
jusque 300 musiciens
on peut même y voir 50 musiciens
jouaient le même instrument
il est donc très facile de se laisser
porter par les autres et on y voit
régulièrement des musiciens de niveau
technique très différent jouer ensemble
pourtant chacun y trouve sa place
c'est ça qui fait qu'on est cohérent
c'est ça qui fait qu'on vivre ensemble
jouer ensemble c'est affirmer ses goûts
développé son style est finalement
s'engager et c'est cela que nous
recherchons l'engagement dans une
activité artistique commune la musique
en 2005
nous sommes partis en guinée à conakry
nous avons découvert pour la première
fois ce qu'est une famille d'artistes
nous sommes partis à prendre au sein
d'un balai un balai c'est une troupe
d'artistes pratiquant différentes formes
d'art on y trouve aussi bien le théâtre
que la danse la musique le chant tout
cela est très organisée et d'ailleurs
on ne dit pas que troupe d'artistes mais
bien famille d'artistes ce voyage nous a
appris énormément et après un mois de
travail acharné
une des dernières questions que nous
avons posées au directeur du ballet
c'était si tu devais nous donner un
conseil
un seul pour nous progresser et évoluer
dans la musique de ta culture quel
serait-il
il nous a regardés avec un grand sourire
et nous a dit c'est simple c'est comme
ça et si vous êtes comme ça le reste
suivra son message était important
n'était pas à jouer comme des fous du
matin au soir
non c'était consolider les liens entre
vous et la musique fonctionnera en nous
disant cela nous a fait comprendre que
tout le monde
tout le monde peut devenir musicien
grâce à la force du groupe
merci merci
[Applaudissements]